me conhecem sabem que eu detesto falar
meu deus q to ai eu estou aqui e tudo
isso veio essa dificuldade de falar em
público vem da infância mesmo né
é porque quando eu era criança meu pai
falava se você não precisa ser a
primeira mas também não precisa ser a
última mas citando a lei no 6 bom ficar
tranquilo que vai tudo dar certo e eu
levei isso para a vida inteira ele
sempre ficou na minha cabeça eu nunca
gostei de aparecer de ficar à frente
sempre fico bem os bastidores e quando
eu ainda era pequena eu aprendi a me
apaixonei pela eletrônico
aí eu comecei em engenharia elétrica eu
sou engenheiro eletricista na fundação
educacional de barretos
lá eu fiquei cinco anos
eu estava muito feliz de ter feito em
engenharia elétrica e quando eu acabei a
faculdade eu entrei numa firma de
segurança só com segurança
parece que está faltando alguma coisa eu
tinha que fazer alguma coisa não estava
feliz assim eu tinha realizado o sonho é
engenheiro eletricista mas estava
faltando ao processo seletivo do
mestrado
vamos ver né tentei processo seletivo
só que eu entrei como aluno especial na
noite especial você tá da faculdade que
está cursando pós-graduação mas você não
tem um vínculo ainda possa cuidar e
porque geralmente quando você vem de uma
escola particular
existe muito preconceito e em relação à
os estudantes das escolas particulares e
para você provar que você é capaz você
tem que ficar um tempo mostrando
os professores que você consegue fazer
aquele trabalho
e foi assim que eu entrei numa estrada
depois de muitos nãos bacana porta de
muita gente pedindo um orientador
procurando um ambientador ouvir um sim
por causa desse eu tô aqui apresentando
uma história pra vocês
essa pessoa foi muito importante na
minha vida porque ela realmente
acreditou em mim e eu consegui fazer o
mestrado doutorado na área de
telecomunicações
depois desse tempo depois do mestrado
doutorado é eu quando se está fazendo
pesquisa você pesquisa você faz ser
público ativo você só pensa na tela no
seu projeto de mestrado doutorado você
não pensa mais em outras coisas mas na
usp de um dos momentos que a gente
estava no horário do almoço na pracinha
e de umas bandas umas bandas que tocavam
de s
mpb e eu acho tão legal mas só que eu
não saber ontem que quer aquilo que se
está pesquisava eu era um avante
pós-graduação tinha tempo para essas
outras coisas
e foi nessa época que eu pensei nossa
isso é legal mas tudo bem depois quando
tiver mais tempo eu vejo que que é isso
aí acabou a gravação eu entrei numa
faculdade particular dando aula fiquei
lá mais ou menos uns três anos e eu
continuei pesquisando e dá lá mas é
pesquisa gostou gostou dela quando tudo
dá errado e dá aquela sensação de
negócios está testando testando nada dá
certo
de repente negócio funciona nós uma
sensação maravilhosa e depois é surgiu o
concurso
enfim eu pensei nossa já pensei um monte
de concursos será que isso vai dar
aí vamos tentar e foi bem na época do
natal fossem se não der certo acabou
natal não vai ter mais natal mas eu
passei aqui hoje
o tabu bom aí quando eu entrei na unifei
eles falaram 'se você tem que trabalhar
em três anos de pesquisa ensino extensão
e ensino tá tranquilo já dava aulas
realizadas pesquisas e continua
pesquisando aquilo que você já pesquisar
ou aaa
parece coisa diferente as novas é
interesse nosso interesse agora extensão
que que a extensão jesus nosso senhor
que será a sua extensão tem idéia do que
seja isso
e aí foi que eu descobri a extensão foi
o primeiro contato que eu tive com a
extensão da minha vida aí eu aparecer um
projeto é fazer um projeto de
informática na escola cruzam digital
vamos fazer para o projeto de material
reciclável tudo bem vamos lá fazer mas
sempre com aquela mensagem meu pai não
precisa estar na frente então eu sempre
ficava sempre com participantes do
acordo ele nunca e desde essa época
tinha ordenado é um projeto de extensão
aí surgiu em 2015
eu estava fazendo parte da equipe de
transição é da gestão e eu fui convidada
para ser a coordenadora adjunta de
extensão e agora faço aceito não aceito
aí falei vamos tentar é porque é igual
jiló recorde pessoal assim como é
gostoso de lojas home gostoso vai gostar
eu vou experimentar nem foi que eu gosto
a gente não é gostoso é onde eu não
gosto só pra ficar
e aí eu entrei na eleição aí eu eu
conheço eu comecei realmente me envolver
com a extensão
aí surgiu o projeto quadrados
o projeto vai tarde foi fugir mas mesmo
esse jeito eu ea minha admite titular
a gente pensava muito igual e eu falei
pra ela desses dessas bandas que
aconteceu lá na usp e seguia
o campus fica muito distante e o pessoal
fica preparado na hora do almoço e tem
muito que fazer a gente podia criar um
projeto um projeto cultural e alguma
música dança e pessoal deu pra ficar só
para distrair chorar comuns
aí a gente pensou na época e fazer algo
mensal porque daria trabalho eo pessoal
teria pelo menos uma vez no mês alguma
coisa para se distrair
só que a gente não entendia muito assim
de apresentação cultural
a gente conversou com o professor joão
lucas mensal não pessoal vai demorar um
mês para de um projeto de uma
apresentação pra outra coisa semam e as
22 aceitar gente que loucura semanal é a
alimentação é é transporte é palco toda
semana você tem que preparar um evento é
muito cansativo e mesmo assim apesar de
todo esse estresse do pata quarta que eu
tive com quarta ele era emocionante
porque eu chorava eu tb lava eu ficava
feliz era uma mistura de sentimentos mas
ele me dá uma satisfação maravilhoso
porque eu lembro do primeiro quarto os
meninos de minas
aí eles apresentaram um caminhão e foi
tão tão legal o pessoal todo mundo
dançando todo mundo cantando no o
geralmente fica parado não feito
estressado esperando a próxima aula como
não tem nada pra fazer eo quarta ele
essa parte do quarto extensão que o que
me trouxe tanta coisa tanta gente
interessante me fez me aproximar mais os
alunos porque eu eu sou professora do
sistema de comunicação é uma matéria
totalmente teor de sete horas da manhã
os alunos não gostam muito de mim
principalmente ele reprova o mundo
tá então quarta mostrou uma outra
pergunta que eles não conheciam
então é meu eu me aproximei ele aproxima
de pessoas são nunca conheceria se eu
tivesse ficado só na equipe no ensino e
na pesquisa
isso foi muito importante pra mim eu
aprendia eu aprendia e um era como se eu
tivesse um aquário e de repente eu e
rumar assim que conheci sabia de uma
maneira totalmente diferente porque eu
conheço gente da cultura eu conhecia a
gente de escola que dava seu projeto
interessantíssimo na escola e isso é
maravilhoso então eu acho que a extensão
na minha opinião a extensão ela para
aqueles que ainda não sabe muito bem que
a intenção existe o artigo 207 da
constituição de 88 que a instituição de
ensino superior
ela deve operar de forma indissociável
em filho pesquisa extensão e esses são
os três na área da comunidade acadêmica
deve ser a cor deve se apoiar em só que
em tese ela deveria ser de forma
equivalente isso geralmente acontece e
eu eu acredito que a extensão ela muda o
jeito do aluno pensar da universidade
então é o que eu penso assim com a
extensão eu aprendi muita coisa
principalmente nessa mesma época que eu
estava em quarto a gente teve uma união
com a selva do rio de minas e ela tinha
pensava a querendo fazer o tombamento do
tão do tambor mineiro e eu eu
nessa reunião eu pensei nossa gente
podia caracterizar esse instrumento
através do processamento de sinais é e
eu pensei vou chamar um lado do quarteto
está muito interessado fazer a iniciação
científica e ele é
o músico é o felipe o felipe caiu
perfeitamente projeto
então o que a gente pensou o felipe e
até os meninos e meninas aprenderia a
qual construir o hotel camboa que se
eles fazem de materiais reciclados ea
gente dentro da universidade
a gente ia passar toda aquela
caracterização matemática é toda vez que
o espectro de freqüência semelhante aos
com aos tambores comerciais e assim
surgiu o projeto aplicação de materiais
recicláveis pra construção de
instrumentos de percussão o tambor
mineiro e ilegal de extensão é isso
porque foram pessoas diferentes de lugar
diferentes pensando numa mesma coisa ou
seja a gente juntou idéias de pessoas
que talvez nunca se único livro sem
atenção e eu acredito que se a gente
quanto à extensão eu gosto mudar a
maneira de pensar da universidade porque
a extensão ela ela tem essa troca
essa troca de conhecimentos eu vou
conhecer pessoas diferentes que vão
representar coisas diferentes e isso só
enriquece o crescimento da universidade
e eu penso que a universidade pode
crescer de uma maneira saudável se a
gente começar a trabalhar
a extensão de uma forma de tv diferente
de tratar a extensão diferente porque
isso é pesquisa também um projeto de
extensão pode ser projeto de pesquisa e
é isso que eu acredito e caminha na
minha opinião a junção da do ensino da
pesquisa e da extensão
elas só podem melhorar o preá a
universidade e e o que eu acho assim que
hoje eu estou mas nem a coordenação do
quarto nem na coordenação do da extensão
na coordenação de extensão
mas eu acredito que a intenção mudou do
assim o meu jeito de ver a a faculdade
universidade ela ela prossegue a
princípio me aproximou
a cidade e com a extensão eu acho que as
pessoas com é a cidade pode ver a
universidade uma maneira diferente
porque eu não vou ser mais aquela seu
filho dentro de um aquário eu penso
assim
é eu vou só a universidade toda poderosa
você não chega perto de mim mas se eu a
minha profunda do dono da comunidade e
fala olha que vocês preciso que que é o
que a universidade pode contribuir pra
você
isso só melhora o crescimento e só
aproxima mais da sociedade da
universidade e e atenção além dessa
parte tecnológica e ela ainda tem a
parte cultural que era o quadro fazia
ela trazia artistas ela trazer cantores
gente de fora para dentro da
universidade que talvez seja destino a
gente não tiver esse projeto tensão
muitos alunos não devem nunca iriam
conhecer então eu acredito nisso se a
gente pensar na extensão de uma forma
diferente só tem a contribuir e o que
tem são fez comigo
pensando assim agora naquelas palavras
como pai dizia eu eu cheguei à conclusão
que às vezes é bom sair um pouco do meio
que eu fiz não você pode botar as suas
experiências e à extensão que me ajudou
a me libertar essas palavras você não
precisa ficar no meio dessa primeira e
ficar no meio mas sendo mais estando no
meio você está bem obrigado gente